Professor Donald
Kagan: Before I start on
today's topic,
which is Greek tyranny,
I have been asked to say a word
on the subject--well,
to answer the question really
best I can,
if the hoplite phalanx was so
stunningly successful in the
period of the sixth,
fifth, fourth centuries B.C.,
why was it that other peoples,
other than the Greeks,
the ones who came in contact
with them and saw it and were
victimized by it,
why didn't they adopt it?
Well, let me make it perfectly
clear like all the other
interesting questions in this
course, I cannot give you a firm
answer.
I can only give you opinions.
But that whole subject now is
so wonderfully more
controversial than it was
probably ever before in history,
because everything now in
history that bears on the
western world and its relations
with some other world is part of
a great political assault by
those people who are eager to
pull down anything that seems to
be admirable or special,
or positive about the West.
And needless to say,
they say that it really was bad
or to say wasn't so terrific,
or it didn't exist.
So, that's the context in
which, not the students'
question, but the larger
question is getting kicked
around these days.
Well, I think part of the
reason for unhappiness about it
is that I think the answer lies
in the character precisely of
the polis.
The fact that it had an ethos,
a set of values,
which placed so powerfully at
the center of the minds of the
citizens,
the notion that the combination
of courage in a military setting
which was the inheritance of
Homer and the new ideology of
devotion to the polis as
the most important kind of
commitment that a citizen could
have.
This produced an attitude which
was that it was the job of a man
who was a citizen of a
polis,
beyond anything else,
to fight bravely in the ranks
of his army.
As it happened,
they developed--I think this
latter part of the story,
is simply accidental--they
happened to develop this
technique which employed the
weapons and defensive armor that
they had and then because they
had those things,
and because this ethos was
present, it was possible to put
together this fighting unit
which was the phalanx which
depended so enormously heavily
upon the commitment to the
commonality,
to the common cause that was
characteristic of the
polis.
Now, every state of every
kind, every people,
and every tribe has some degree
of this kind of commitment to
one another or else they
wouldn't exist as a unit.
But there are really very sharp
differences of degree in terms
of how powerfully this
commitment really affects
people.
You would find in the same
people, at different times in
their history,
the power of this idea and this
commitment and it's beyond an
idea somehow.
It's sort of really bred and
trained into the bones of every
Greek man in the polis
beginning sometime,
I would say,
in the seventh century or
earlier and carrying forward,
so long as the polis
remained an autonomous and
independent unit.
So, Greeks against Persians is
the best case we have,
because the Greeks fought the
Persians more than they fought
other non-Greek peoples and the
Persians were very formidable.
Let's remember the Persians had
defeated every other power there
was in the world that they knew,
and controlled and dominated a
vast, vast empire by anybody's
standards, but certainly by the
standards of the world in which
they knew.
So, for the Greeks to defeat
the Persians,
there was nothing routine about
that;
that was always going to be
surprising and needing
explanation.
So really a way to focus the
question that I'm addressing is
how come the Persians didn't do
it?
There I think,
in that case,
the answer is not so very hard,
because the Persian Empire was
a composite unit made up of lots
of places and vast numbers of
people who had been conquered by
the Persians,
and whose relationship to the
great King of Persia was really
an almost technical sense,
that of slaves.
They needed to do,
they had to do,
they were expected to do,
whatever the Persian king told
them to do.
Now, he was not fanatical and
he did not make requests that
typically were impossible for
people to do.
In fact, the Persian rule over
their conquered peoples was,
in many ways,
easier and more generous and
less intrusive than other
peoples.
For instance,
in the realm of religion,
the Persians did not bother;
they didn't interfere with
people's exercise of religion.
Those of you who have read a
book called, The Old
Testament,
will remember that the Persians
show up at important places and
they get treated very nicely.
There's a bad Persian or two
here or there,
but he gets put down,
but the Persians treat and the
Persians were among the people
who treated the Jews very well,
because they didn't care what
the Jews did in their religious
life, so long as they did the
two important and essential
things that the Persians
required,
which was you had to do
military service for the king at
his demand and you had to pay
taxes.
If you did those things and
made no trouble that's all you
had to worry about from the
Persians.
Well okay,
why didn't the Persians then
adopt it?
Because the greater part of
their army wasn't Persian even.
So, the kinds of allegiance
that's necessary for this kind
of fighting wasn't motivated by
most of these people.
A second reason was the
Persians themselves and their
Arian allies,
the Medes,
had achieved their success
militarily as cavalrymen and
that was their nature,
and that was what they
practiced and elevated to the
highest levels,
so that the best Persians
fought in the cavalry.
They had infantry and some of
their infantry was relatively
very good, but there wasn't that
kind of--all that matters in a
polis basically,
I'm exaggerating only very
slightly, is how you fight in
the infantry.
Happily, that question isn't so
bad because when we get to the
story of the Spartans,
which comes after our story of
the tyrants, I will read to you
some of the poetry which was the
material with which Spartans
were trained,
and you'll quickly see why the
Greek ethos, the Greek feeling
of absolute commitment,
voluntary absolute commitment,
even at the risk of your life
for the polis was the
central most important force in
society.So,
the answer is essentially a
moral commitment,
based upon training and belief.
This is why the Greeks did the
phalanx, and plus the historical
accident of their having
developed that technique.
It should be pointed out that
there were peoples in the
Ancient Near East,
before the Greeks ever came to
be anything,
who had closely ordered,
armed infantry soldiers.
The Assyrians are a very good
example.
But if you examine Assyrian
fighting, it's not quite the
same thing as the Greek
fighting,
and if I knew more about
Assyrian fighting I might be
able to say still more.
I don't know how much is
actually known in detail,
but there was obviously an
element in the Greek story which
went beyond merely equipment,
and order, and so on.
It had to do with what was in
their heads.
I think if you know about
warfare in the modern world,
even today, so much of what
determines whether armies
succeed or fail in their
missions has to do with what's
in their head.
Every army, I think,
let's say every good army even,
is good at certain things and
they are trained,
and their culture prepares if
they are successful to do
certain kinds of things.
If you take them and make them
fight in a different way,
until they are able to make an
adjustment which is sometimes
never,
they can fight with that same
skill.
So, there is a very close
union, I would say,
and I'll come back and I'll say
a smarter guy than I,
said it long ago.
There's a close connection
between the nature of the
society that produces and uses
the military force and the kind
of fighting that military force
can do.
I'm really just giving you a
little riff on a tune written by
Aristotle back in his day,
when he connects closely to
character, which I think I
mentioned that the other day.
The character of a regime and
the character of the fighting;
I did tell you about that.
You know if it's going to be
cavalry based,
it's going to be aristocratic
or oligarchic.
If it's going to be navel
based, it's going to be
democratic, and so on and so
forth, so I hope that's of some
help in dealing with that
question.
Let's turn now precisely to
this phenomenon which is Greek
tyranny.
Tyranny emerges in the seventh
century B.C.,
maybe it might have--no I think
it emerges,
I would think,
for many of the same reasons
and in response to some of the
very same developments that I
described for you in talking
about the great burst of
colonization that began in the
eighth century in the Greek
world.
All of those tumultuous,
troubling, changing forces that
were at work in society were at
work in bringing about this new
kind of regime,
which lasted from one to three
generations among the Greeks
before it faded away.
It was a transitional phase in
Greek society,
rather than one that lasted for
a terribly long time,
but it was not trivial,
and, as I say,
in some cases it went for three
generations.
Okay, what is tyranny?
Let's begin with the word.
The word tyranneia is
tyranny, the word
tyrannos is tyrant,
and etymologically the word is
not a Greek word.
It was a borrowed word that the
Greeks took from somebody else
and then applied it to certain
elements that emerged in their
society.
Chances are it was borrowed
from Lydia, that kingdom in Asia
Minor that was inland from the
Greek settlements on the coast.
The first Lydian king,
of whom we hear that could fit
as the first tyrant from Greek
perspective was a man called
Gyges,
who ruled in Lydia from
something like the years 685 to
657, something like that.
The first time the word
tyrannos or some version
of it appears in Greek that we
have comes in the fragments of
the poet,
Archilochus,
and he is a fascinating
character.
We do have fortunately a few
nice fragments of his poetry.
In fact, for the first time in
the last couple of decades,
for the first time,
since they were lost,
we actually have a full lyric
poem by Archilochus.
But in any case he has this bit
of poetry that is preserved in a
late writer's collection which
says,
"I don't care for the wealth of
golden Gyges,
nor have I ever envied him.
I am not jealous of the works
of the gods and I have no desire
for lofty tyranny."
This is where the word tyranny
comes into the picture.
Even in that small
collection of words,
you get some idea of what the
Greeks meant by tyranny.
They were talking about
tremendous power from their
perspective and its golden
Gyges, and that's not an
accident.
They mean wealthy Gyges;
tyrants are people who have
lots of wealth and lots of
power, and they also rule.
One translation that poets give
for tyrannidos is lofty
despotism, that he rules not as
an equal,
he rules not as a legitimate
king, he rules as a master
ruling slaves is the implication
of that.
It comes from the Greek
perspective, it comes from the
east, it is not native to
Greeks,
it is something new in the
Greek experience,
they haven't had kings like
that even in their legends.
So, that's going to be a
central idea that surrounds the
concept of tyranny.
The Greek word that comes
closest to it,
but it doesn't do the same job
is monarchos,
our word monarch and that
simply means a ruler who is one,
a single ruler.
Well, you know you need a
word for that in Greek because
that's not the natural thing in
Greece.
As you know already,
every regime that we have
discussed from the Homeric world
on,
post Bronze Age,
shows multiple kings as in the
Iliad and the
Odyssey,
yes there is the generalissimo,
you remember Agamemnon,
but everybody there is a king.
There's not just one king;
so that's the Greek way of
looking at things,
whereas, the rest of the world
and if the Greeks had only
known,
any where you look in the rest
of the world,
the typical regime is monarchy
of one kind or another,
absolute power.
Nobody in Greece has absolute
power in the Greek point of
view, but kings elsewhere do.
But there's another sense
that Greeks attach to the word
tyrannos or
tyranneia,
and that is that the power is
not legitimately acquired.
The Greeks could understand
that there'd be somebody called
the basileus,
and that reason he was
basileus was that his
father was, and that the regime
of that state is royal and this
is a perfectly legitimate
regime.
The Greeks, although they don't
practice kingship during the
period that we study,
they don't regard that as an
illegitimate form of regime.
Kingship is legitimate;
tyranny is not and I want to
spell that out for you.
But before we get to my
spelling it out for you,
let me just give it a few more
of the characteristics that it
comes to have by classical times
in the minds of the Greeks.
It is, as I say,
despotically exercised.
It is not legitimate and one
aspect of its not being
legitimate is that it is not
responsible.
A tyrannos does not have
to explain himself and nobody
would dare insist that he do.
He need not consult anybody if
he doesn't want to.
He doesn't need to have the
approval of anybody.
All of that makes him
illegitimate.
Irresponsible is another I
think that fits into the
picture, because we shall see
that certainly by the Classical
Period the Greeks felt that any
regime to be legitimate must be
responsible in the technical
sense.
It must be answerable to
somebody because all human
beings, was the philosophical
core of this idea,
are not to be trusted by
complete power.
They will abuse it,
they will abuse it with
violence, and that violence will
very often mean sexual violence,
but it will take every other
form as well.
Let's go back to
Archilochus' few words which are
so rich in telling us so much
about it.
He says, "I am not jealous of
the works of the gods."
What's that got to do with
anything?
Well, the Greek view of tyranny
was that tyrants,
and one of the things that's
wrong with tyrants,
is that they see themselves as
rivaling the gods,
as thinking themselves to be
divine,
or at least thinking that they
could act as though they were
gods.
And because they have the power
and the wealth,
and because they have no
responsibility to anybody,
presumably they can,
and this is one of the things
that makes them terrible.
It's this act of behaving as
though they were gods that
Greeks called hubris,
this arrogant,
this violent,
arrogant kind of exercise of
power.
That is the way things looked
fundamentally in the Classical
Period.
But even in the Classical
Period there was a remnant of
what I think,
and most scholars I think would
agree,
was the special characteristic
of the idea in its earlier
days--which was not so much how
evil tyranny was,
because in the early days it's
not clear that they thought it
was, but because of the fact
that it was not legitimately
acquired.
It was not part of the
normal way things happened,
and I've mentioned this to you
earlier.
A good example of that is
Oedipus Tyrannos,
Oedipus the King.
Notice that nobody translates
it as Oedipus the tyrant.
They are right not to do so,
because it would mislead us.
The way we use the word tyrant,
it's always bad.
There's no good tyrant.
But you will often see it
translated, Oedipus
Rex, into the Latin,
but Rex means king.
So, Oedipus the King is okay.
Actually, it's not bad to say
Oedipus Rex,
because the Romans had this
idea that kings were bad;
so there's a little bit of that
glittering around the edge,
but for the Greeks that's not
there at the beginning.
The contemporaries of Gyges
and the tyrants that came after
him in Greece probably didn't
use the term yet.
It probably sprang up at a
later time, but we can't be sure
of that.
For the Greeks it originally
meant something much more
neutral, without this great
moral baggage to carry with it.
It simply meant more than
anything else,
two things.
One man rule,
well that would always raise an
eyebrow, but you could imagine
it being okay,
and the fact that it was
unconstitutional.
It did not come about in a way
that followed tradition,
which was what Greek
constitutions were,
traditional sets of laws or
customs.
Okay, that's the general
picture;
let's take a look at tyranny as
it emerges in Greece,
and we don't know very much
about it.
Here's another one of these
cases where we are dependent on
later sources,
we have no--I think I'm right
in saying nothing really
contemporary at all that speaks
about any tyrant and so that's a
problem,
but we have to deal with that.
Then there are very limited
tales that are told about them,
so that we have to piece
together a lot of information
and ask ourselves what it all
means.
In any case,
the first tyrant named in the
Greek tradition is a man called
Pheidon of Argos,
who is mentioned by Aristotle
in his Politics,
and he says some interesting
things.
I'll come back in a moment,
but here are some of the facts
or alleged facts that surround
Pheidon in the Greek tradition.
He is the King of Argos,
and Argos you know in the
Homeric tradition is a very big,
powerful, important place;
Argos includes Mycenae and all
of that.
So, this would be a king of a
large and important area.
The Argives and Pheidon as
king of Argos,
were engaged in a conflict with
Sparta as to who would be the
dominant force in the
Peloponnesus,
and they fought a battle at a
place called Hysiae in the 668
in which the Argives in a fight
undefeated the Spartans,
and really defeated him;
it wasn't just a little
skirmish.
They were now the top dog,
as proven by the following
other alleged facts about what's
going on here.
Pheidon got himself elected
chairman, president of the
Olympic Festival.
That was a tremendous honor and
it indicated deference to him
and scholars suggest,
if it really happened,
it would have suggested that
the Argives and Pheidon were the
dominant force in the
Peloponnesus.
And there is further evidence,
and this is really rather
better evidence,
I think even than that.
It is the fact,
I don't hesitate to use that
fact, that Pheidon or Argos
apparently imposed a system of
uniform weights and measures on
the entire Peloponnesus and
those remained the weights and
measures employed in the
Peloponnesus thereafter,
so that they were called the
Pheidonian measures.
You don't do that if you're not
in effective control of the
region.
Nothing is more basic than
determining something like that.
So I think that lends
considerable plausibility to the
general story.
It is also said that he was
a leader of the army,
which was a hoplite army,
and that his success depended
upon his successful leadership
of the hoplite army.
Well, that fits in with one
general interpretation that
scholars have used about the
rise of tyrants.
Nobody claims it's universal,
but one feature that seems to
be plausibly present is that the
new way of fighting in the
hoplite phalanx,
which was to turn out to be
decisive, well that brought
about the leaders who were very
good leaders of hoplite
phalanxes and should they decide
to seize power in any state
where they had been doing the
leadership,
they could typically count on
their army, the army they had
led to assist them--all which
makes obvious sense if you're
going to get the fighting force
around and they like you and
you're popular,
and you want to be a boss,
that's your best shot.
So, tradition also lends some
small support to the idea that
maybe that's how Pheidon brought
himself to the kingship.
Before I depart,
I just feel it necessary to
make one small point.
I said weights and measures.
There are elements in the
ancient tradition that also say
that Pheidon was the first
man--I want to put it very
carefully and literally,
because it's all part of the
argument.
He was the first man to strike
silver coins on the island of
Aegina.
Coins have not been present in
Greece prior to this time and
the most well-informed and
professionally skilled and
capable people,
and almost everybody who
studies the subject says,
this is false.
There were no coins in the
Greek world yet and there aren't
going to be any for a very long
time afterwards.
So, this is merely a myth.
I'm sorry to say that in spite
of the fact that I am not an
expert, or a numismatist,
and everybody's against me,
they're all wrong.
I won't put you through the
pain of listening to the
argument, but just keep in the
back of your mind one day
somebody's going to find hard
evidence that I'm absolutely
right about this,
and so then you can tweak and
say, aha because that's it.
But right now no sensible
person that has any credit in
the field at all believes me.
There are about two or three
people maybe,
but that's about it.
Another very interesting
important element about Pheidon.
Aristotle tells us he was a
king who became a tyrant,
and by now you know the Greek
words, he was basileus,
who became tyrannos.
Now, how did he do that?
You would think if a man was
king and that implies
legitimacy, how do you become an
illegitimate thing like a
tyrant?
We can only speculate,
but I think from what we've
learned already about the early
Greek kings in those towns that
had any,
that they were Homeric kings.
They were not really monarchs;
they were not really powerful
rulers.
They did not simply dominate
everybody and give orders.
They were maybe the most
striking, or the best connected,
or the best descended of a
bunch of noblemen who were
roughly equal.
Well, if we imagine that's the
way Pheidon began and then--I'm
just making up the story you
understand--then he himself led
the Argive phalanx to these
tremendous successes,
defeating the Spartans,
establishing Argos as the
president of the Olympic Games,
giving weights measures and
heaven help us maybe coins to
the people of the Peloponnesus
and then began to act as though
he really was the boss,
because he could,
and people recognized that and
said, you know he's not just
king anymore,
he has made himself a
tyrannos.
Something like that would make
sense of Aristotle's statement.
Now, this raises the
question, which is to be raised
whenever we think about
tyrannos coming to power
in Greece.
Okay, he wants to be king,
he's popular and all those
things, but what does it take?
Well, it takes military force
because there are people who are
going to resist and so I would
suggest,
again nothing original about
this, that the positive
connection with the hoplite army
now emerging in these states has
to be part of the story.
Why would these hoplites
support a tyranny?
It doesn't really accord with
their own long range interest or
the autonomy and the
independence that are so clearly
a part of what it is to be a
hoplite farmer.
Well, I think the best answer
would be that that's what had to
be done to break the monopoly of
power and influence of the old
aristocracy,
which would have been
presumably resisting the changes
in society that were part of
that hoplite uprising,
that development of hoplites,
the movement towards a hoplite
community and so they joined
with a leader who had what it
took to make it work and to
destroy the power of the
aristocracy and to create a new
kind of state with a new kind of
constitution.
But the first step would have
been a tyranny,
because that's the way they got
to where they had to go in the
first instance.
Now, this is easy to
connect again,
theoretically,
because we just don't have the
kind of hard evidence that would
make it possible to be sure--to
join this hoplite development
with other changes that are
occurring in society,
and that is to say,
the economic change that means
trade is becoming more and more
important and so is simple
industry.
There are now people in society
who by virtue of what they do to
make a living,
get ahead, don't fit in to the
traditional aristocratic system,
who don't have what they want
in terms of influence,
power, recognition,
because there hasn't been a
place for such people before and
the people who are in charge are
not about to give it away very
readily,
and so they might very well
also assist.
Let us imagine,
the hoplite farmers as being
the guys who do the fighting for
the most part,
but joined and supported by
these other elements in society
who need a change for the same
reason.
That fits rather nicely with
where we find the earliest
colonies.
Argos is a special place
but Argos, in addition to being
a fine agricultural area,
also from an early time had
commercial activity.
So, that would be good.
But then on top of that,
the next three towns I'm going
to mention as being very active
in colonization--you're familiar
with that from our last talk,
Corinth and a little town that
I haven't mentioned before,
but it's right next to Corinth
and surely was part of the same
set of developments that we've
described there,
a place called Sicyon.
It also has an early tyrannical
family and Megara which is
located--I should say Sicyon is
sort of to the south and to the
west of Corinth,
and Megara is to the north and
to the east or Corinth.
It's right on and around the
Isthmus of Corinth that some of
these early states that have
tyrants come into being,
just as these are states that
are very, very active in the
colonial movement.
If we go away from the
mainland, again,
Miletus has a tyrant at a
fairly early time,
just as you would expect,
because it fits into the whole
picture.
You don't have tyrannies
very early, if at all,
in places like Athens.
We will have a famous tyrant,
but that will come later.
Thebes will not have a tyrant
in spite of the mythology
surrounding Oedipus.
Sparta, of course,
never has the tyrant so all of
this is sort of reasonable
support for the interpretation
that most scholars take.
So, you have all of this stuff,
the pressure of a growing
population, new groups
challenging the aristocracy,
hoplites among them.
If you go to Corinth the story
of the establishment of a
tyranny there involves an
individual called Cypselus,
and the stories that are told
about Cypselus fit pretty
decently into what we've been
talking about.
He is specifically a
polemarch,
which means the war
archon,
the war leader.
He was commander of the army in
Corinth, and at that time that
would have been a hoplite army.
But he was not a king like
Pheidon;
he was, according to the
myth--I shouldn't say myth,
because it isn't a myth.
According to the legend--no,
it's not really even a legend;
let's say tradition.
According to the tradition,
Cypselus was a descendant from
a mixed marriage between a
patrician, an aristocrat and
somebody who was not.
So, that's a very sort of
typical historical development;
people who become
revolutionaries and
troublemakers are often people
on the margin,
but who have by birth some kind
of a connection or think they
have some kind of a connection
with the higher ranks and are
annoyed,
irritated, angry,
jealous and therefore likely to
take the trouble to seize power.
I mean, Napoleon descended from
some kind of Corsican
aristocracy.
Of course, the French thought
that that was--what is it when a
word contradicts itself?
What's the word?
No not paradox,
oxymoron, that's right.
The French thought it was an
oxymoron, a Corsican aristocrat;
I mean ridiculous.
But that was his feeling and
that kind of French attitude
helped, I think explain,
the drive that he had to get
ahead to the way he did.
Anyway, Cypselus was one of
that group.
Corinth, I might point out,
was an unusual polis
before the emergence of the
tyranny,
because most polis as
best we can figure it out,
they had an aristocracy that
consisted of many,
many, many, many families,
but Corinth had the narrowest
of all aristocracies.
One family who were called the
Bacchiads completely monopolized
the regime and so that meant it
would be easier once you've
started to make trouble,
to find help against them from
a rather powerful people who
were in other states,
likely to be part of the
regime, but here were cut out.
So, Cypselus puts together
a force of military folks with
some folks who are discontented
and finally attacks the
Bacchiads,
either killed them or drove
them into exile and then he
establishes his own regime,
which is in fact,
one of the most successful
tyrannies, at least as judged by
the most basic thing,
how long do they last?
Cypselus, in effect,
died in bed leaving the tyranny
to his son and then his son had
another son who became tyrant
and he was driven out finally,
and he was the last of them.
So the Cypselid tyranny is a
very successful one and we know
something about it.
The colonization movement,
which the Corinthians had
already started,
but it really took a real hold
in the time of the Cypselus,
and so Corinth is colonizing
quite vigorously in the time of
the Cypselid tyranny,
mostly, out in the west,
that sort of empty territory
from a Greek point of view,
and so you will see Corinthian
colonies stretching out along
the shore, the north shore of
the Gulf of Corinth,
and north shore is less Greek
and more barbaric than the south
shore which is the Peloponessus.
Then if you go to the end of
Greece as far west as you go,
and make a right turn and head
up into the Adriatic region--I'm
sorry,
the Ionian Sea and beyond that
the Adriatic.
Corinthian colonies are
right along in there and they
suggest, and I think they're
supported by other
archaeological evidence,
that commerce was one of the
things that was very important
for Cypselus and Corinth is
booming from a commercial
economic point of view in the
years of the Cypselid tyrants.
None of that is surprising,
all of this is very
characteristic of this phase of
Greek tyranny that we're talking
about.
In addition to that,
we know that Cypselus like just
about all the tyrants used his
power to do something that the
Greek governments normally did
not do,
namely, collect taxes from
their people.
You have to understand that the
idea of taxation being normal
would have gotten a Greek
foaming at the mouth.
When there is no tyranny,
there's no taxes,
no direct tax I should say.
The normal form of taxation
that existed in the Greek world,
when it was in its independent
polis phase,
is simply customs duties on
trade.
But the hoplite farmer wasn't
going to be taxed.
Paying taxes is what barbarians
did to their kings,
a very powerful feeling.
People like that in America
today used to be called
republicans.
No surprise that Cypselus
and his descendants,
just like the other tyrants,
were very wealthy.
There was undoubtedly wealth
they seized when they took
power, but there was also wealth
that they could enjoy from the
tremendous income that would
come from the booming commerce,
and then finally taxation.
Just put it right smack from
somebody hands into theirs and
so tremendous wealth is another
picture that goes with this.
If you go to Sicyon,
another element comes into the
picture, which may or may not
have occurred in other
tyrannical towns.
We do know that it played a
role in Sicyon.
There, the founder of the
tyranny was a man called
Orthagoras, and again,
one thing we are told about him
is that he was polemarch,
leader of the phalanx.
So we understand that.
Another story says that he was
a cook and they didn't mean an
Escoffier, or anything like
that.
I mean that was not a high
ranking position,
and so I think the implication
was he came from a very low
source.
We don't know what to do with
that;
it sounds surprising,
but maybe it's true.
Anyway, we get down to the
point where one of his
descendants is still tyrant;
I think it's his son,
Cleisthenes of Sicyon.
Well, now you want to keep that
name in your mind and you want
to keep it straight,
there will be a descendant of
that guy, who will be an
Athenian, whose name is
Cleisthenes,
he will not only be later but
thoroughly different;
not a tyrant,
quite different from that.
So just remember this is
Cleisthenes of Sikyon as opposed
to Cleisthenes,
the Athenian.
Well, the picture that
Herodotus, who is one of our
main sources here,
the main source I guess,
gives us in Sicyon,
is one of political oppression
of a kind that we haven't run
into yet because it is based
on--really on ethnic origins and
ethnic differences.
Here we see,
I think without any question,
a case of the pre-Dorian Greeks
who have been defeated and
conquered by Dorians and these
groups have been kept separate
throughout the centuries,
and one was top dog and the
other was the underdog.
So, what has happened obviously
is that part of the tyrants
coming to power must have been a
reversal of that situation,
because the leading forces are
anti-Dorian, very powerfully
anti-Dorian.
They hate Argos,
because Argos in the
Iliad and the
Odyssey,
the great leader of the
Peloponnesians,
the wrong guys,
and of course Argos in their
day is a Dorian city.
You don't have to go back to
the Iliad and the
Odyssey.
I should have--I mean back to
the days of Pheidon,
the Argives would have ruled
Sicyon presumably if Pheidon was
in charge.
Well, they didn't like that;
they had achieved I presume,
an overthrow of that.
So, they're anti-Argos,
anti-Dorian and they introduced
changes in the tribes.
If you go to any Dorian town in
the Greek world,
there are three tribes,
they have the same names in all
Dorian towns and that's the way
the world is organized.
So what did they do?
These guys, the Orthagorids
changed the tribes.
That's interesting too because
we'll see that Cleisthenes the
Athenian does the same thing.
That's amazing;
that's very rare.
When you're talking about
changes in tribal things,
you're getting at the oldest
possible memories,
and traditions,
and beliefs,
and associations that primitive
peoples have.
So, when you're fussing with
that you're really making a
great problem,
but you'll see in a moment
what's driving this sort of
thing.
Instead of having three tribes
thereafter, from once the
Orthagrads got there,
they had four,
but they changed the names of
the old three.
The old three now were
called--I'm translating the
Greek words, ass men,
pig men,
and swine men whereas the
non-Dorians were the
archelaoi,
leaders of the people.
You can see very objective set
of names and evaluations;
so you've got vengeance here.
You've got a group long
annoyed, long angered,
long feeling oppressed,
taking out their hatred when
the victory comes in.
But once you're past this
peculiarity, this particular
ethnic conflict in this town
that had such an important
effect,
you find that the tyrants are
pretty much like all the other
tyrants.
They have great wealth and
we'll come back in just a moment
to indicate how striking that
was.
They engage in conspicuous
display, which is what tyrants
also do, and they are filled
with a tremendous ego and a
terrific sense of their own
importance and self,
and so the kind of thing that
made Archilochus say,
"I'm not going to try to vie
with the gods the way these
tyrants do."
Well, the story that
Herodotus tells and I think you
will enjoy it,
in his wonderful prose if you
haven't gotten to it yet.
Cleisthenes of Sicyon now is in
charge;
we're in the sixth century
B.C., and he has a daughter and
he wants her to have the very
best husband that there was
available in Greece.
Just like your parents,
he felt the same way as your
parents do, but he was going to
see to it that it was going to
work out.
By the way, he himself was a
very significant figure,
and this again makes him not so
very unusual among the tyrants.
He entered in the Olympic
competition, and in those days,
in probably forever in the
Olympic Games,
I mean the ancient Olympic
Games, the most prestigious,
the most important contest was
the four-horse,
horse race, the chariot race.
For one thing,
you couldn't do that unless you
were very rich.
So, it meant that the noblest
and wealthiest people were
competing against one another in
this.
Well, he was the winner in the
four-horse chariot race which
made him an international
celebrity on top of all the
other things that he had going
for him.
So, he decides by God he's
going to have the best guy in
Greece be his daughter's
husband.
He invites all the best
aristocratic,
richest, handsomest,
most athletic guys in all of
Greece to come to Sicyon and
spend a year,
at his expense,
and treated royally all that
time to compete for the hand of
his daughter and so they all
are.
Herodotus reads off the
names of all of these amazing
young men who come to the
competition,
pretty much I think,
copying Homer's catalog of the
ships in the Iliad and
they come.
Well, after the bulk of this
year, it is clear two finalists
are emerging.
One of them is called
Hippocleides and the other is
called Megacles.
Megacles, we better take
seriously because he's an
Athenian and he will be the
ancestor of Cleisthenes of
Athens later on.
But anyway, they're competing
in every respect,
and we're down to the last
kinds of things and it looks
Hippocleides has on the edge.
He seems to be the number one
candidate and he has quite a few
belts at the party when we're
reaching the final stages of all
this,
and next he jumps on a table
and he begins dancing wildly.
I mean like beyond what is seen
to be seemingly dancing,
we expect a young nobleman to
be a good dancer,
but this guy is doing stuff
that nobody ever heard of and
this is making Cleisthenes a
little nervous.
I mean who is this guy?
What's happening here?
Then he flips upside down and
begins to dance on his hands,
with his feet flipping around
in the air, at which point
Herodotus tells us.
Cleisthenes speaks up and says,
son of Tysander you have danced
your bride away,
he lost and Megacles got to
marry Aragriste and the story
goes on.
Well, what are we to
believe of that tale?
I don't know,
but this much I think is clear.
Such a legend does not come
from nothing.
The picture is first of all of
a man who is fabulously wealthy.
Think of the kind of
entertaining he is said to have
done.
Also, fabulously full of
himself, just imagine saying my
daughter will only marry the
very best young man there is,
and you will all have to go out
there and compete for her hand
and I'll tell you who she's
going to marry.
Who can then act the way he did.
I think that's a picture that
he probably was extreme in all
of these respects and that kind
of situation was part of the
tale.
So, let me just sum up some
things.
Untraditional root to power is
important.
Gyges, perhaps you remember the
story of Gyges.
Gyges was sort of the prime
minister of the King of Lydia
and the king had this incredibly
beautiful wife and he was
terribly proud of her,
and so he said to Gyges,
you can't believe how gorgeous
my wife is, and Gyges says,
of course she's wonderfully
beautiful.
You can't tell with her clothes
on for God's sake.
He says, come on, come with me.
Gyges says, no,
no, no please your majesty.
He says, come with me.
So, there's Gyges hidden behind
a curtain and here's his wife
disrobing and indeed she was as
advertised.
The king goes out,
and Gyges would have slipped
away, but the queen spots him
and, of course,
she's totally disgraced.
She's deeply embarrassed just
to put it very,
very mildly,
and so she says to him,
unless you do what I tell you I
will tell my husband that you
sneaked in and did this and he
will kill you.
But what I want you to do is to
kill him and marry me.
That's how you can make it up.
What could Gyges do?So he
did;
that's how he became king.
This is not your normal
constitutional procedure even in
Lydia.
So that's Gyges;
Pheidon I've talked to you
about already.
Theagenes of Megara I haven't
mentioned, but he comes to power
by force, with the use of the
soldiers and same thing is true
of Cypselas.
All these tyrants get there by
means that are not traditional.
They have personal power,
whatever else is going on,
they have control of the
military,
and the military gives them
what they need in the way of
command.
They have to have skill--the
founder of the dynasty at least
has to have skill.
In order to be a soldier he has
to be a good talker to get
people to go along with him.
He's got to have talent.
It's not the easiest thing in
the world to overthrow a
traditional regime and make
yourself the boss.
He would have had these
qualities, but he's got to have
support out there from the
various elements that I
mentioned to you,
prestige from some great deed,
whatever it might be,
military victory or athletic
victory perhaps.
When he has wealth,
once he's acquired wealth,
he can use it further to
strengthen his position and they
typically do,
because he introduces something
new, mercenary soldiers.
It's one thing to seize the
power with the help of the
hoplites, but to hold onto it
you're going to need something
more solid than that.
First of all,
hoplites don't stick around in
uniform;
they go back and work their
fields.
So, they're not around to
suppress anything that needs to
be suppressed most of the time,
but beyond that tyrants grow
unpopular.
This is one of the great rules
of politics in any system.
The one question that's in the
minds of all people who have
anything to do with it,
and that is what have you done
for me lately?
Any benefit that people might
have achieved from the
establishment of the tyranny
gets to be taken for granted
after awhile they ask why is
this guy taking taxes from me?
Why is he such a big shot and
I'm not?
That's just going to be
inevitable, and so if you're
going to keep your power and
keep people down,
you can't just rely on the
citizen body and so tyrants
typically hire foreigners to
serve as mercenaries for them.
Now, another thing is that
while these tyrannies last,
it is typical that they should
accomplish very significant
things that most anybody would
agree were positive
contributions to the life of the
community they ruled.
You find economic prosperity.
This is one of the things that
is characteristic of these
regimes--diversified economies,
because they support trade and
industry, and sometimes even
agriculture, the spread of
wealth to new groups,
because there's much more money
around, there are people who
don't fit into the old system in
which the land was simply
dominated by the aristocrats and
where there was no other way to
make any money,
or gain any wealth.
So, all of that is happening,
and of course,
many of the tyrants foster and
engage in colonization,
which has all the benefits I
mentioned last time as well.
Now, there's another thing
that is characteristic of
tyrannies.
When they make themselves
tyrant, they come to live,
whether they did before or not,
in what is the major city of
that whole polis;
the capital so to speak.
It's always been a place that
would have a special place;
it's where the acropolis is and
therefore where the worship of
the gods takes place.
There's worship of the gods
everywhere, but that's a special
place for them.
There was always a special
place, but now that becomes the
center of the community,
and as a result where the
tyrant is, that's where all the
action is.
People begin to move into that
capital city if they leave the
land of their fathers,
and some number of them in fact
do.
If you're going to conduct
commercial activity,
if you're conducting factory
work,
and you're going to be somehow
involved in the various aspects
of government and things that
have to do with the tyrant,
you want to be there,
and the tyrants have courts,
and so people come to be in the
court of the tyrant.
So, what you have is a kind of
urbanization that is
characteristic of this period.
Well, if you're going to have
more people living in this town
than ever did before,
there's all sorts of things you
need.
Number one, no question number
one, water supply;
how you supply people with
enough water to meet their needs
when they weren't there before,
and the answer is you have to
bring water into the city by a
variety of ways,
any way that you really can.
They do aqueducts of a certain
kind, they dig wells and have
fountains coming from those
wells;
they build fountain houses to
cover those fountains.
In short, they bring a water
supply.
Also, if you're going to
have these common places where a
lot of people live who didn't
live there before,
drainage is essential or else
you'll have terrible disease
breaking out.
It's not that they were
scientists and knew about germs,
it's just that if you know when
there's a lot of people there
and there's a lot of water lying
around,
people seem to die,
so you don't have to be genius
for that.
There are sewer systems
introduced by these tyrants
which never existed before.
Since they are trying to
encourage trade,
there was always a place--I
shouldn't say there was always,
but at some point in the
development of the polis,
there emerged a kind of central
place in the city called the
agora which was a place
that people came together for
different purposes.
It looks like,
in the beginning,
political meetings,
meetings of the assembly,
for instance,
might take place in the
agora.
It pretty early seemed to have
had some religious significance,
and then over time,
not at the beginning though but
over time, they became
commercial centers.
If you use the word
agora in Greece today,
you're talking about a shop
because that's how much that
comes to be the thing.
But we need to keep in mind
that it is a religious center,
it becomes a civic center,
and it also of course was a
commercial center as well.
So the agoras come from
these tyrannical periods.
Public buildings are
created by the tyrant for
whatever use he needs,
but he might be building
courthouses,
he might be building places for
magistrates to stay,
things like that.
But also, he has a tendency to
try to make them very
attractive, very impressive,
so that people will be
impressed with him for having
done so.
You know the phenomenon;
people like to have their name
on a building.
I'm told they will actually
give you millions and millions
of dollars to put their name on
a building.
I'm told there are places where
they will even give you lots of
money to put their names on
bathroom stalls,
but only the tyrants in their
day would have been rich enough
to do the kind of thing we're
talking about,
including, and this is a very
large thing I believe,
temples.
The Greeks had been building
temples I'm sure for a long
time, but essentially out of
wood.
But now with people having the
kind of wealth that were being
accumulated by these tyrants,
they begin to build them of
stone and where possible of very
fine stone such as marble,
and I think we have to imagine
the construction of such a
building in an old town like any
one of the Greek city states
had,
it would have had at tremendous
impact.
This is something I'd like to
pass on to you,
when you think about the
Greeks.
Here's one of the places where
they're so stunningly different
from us that we need to make an
imaginative leap to understand
what's going on.
Remember this is a world
that has next to no writing.
There are a few people who know
how to write,
but it's not part of life.
Of course, there's no paper.
So, just get writing out of
your life for the most part,
but there's no movies,
there's no television,
there's no radio,
there's no newspapers,
there are very few buildings.
Now suddenly up pops--let's go
to Corinth and suddenly up pops
this incredible thing made of
stone,
a temple to the gods,
decorated beautifully,
painted typically blue and red,
and gold with a big statue of
the goddess and anybody in town
can go by and look at that.
That would have made a
sensational experience and
people would have been talking
about it in various elements of
detail forever and a day,
and they would not forget,
who it was that constructed
that temple.
So, that's an example of what
I'm talking about.
Beyond that,
the tyrants were patrons of the
arts, by which I mean
architects,
sculptors, painters,
painters of this,
that, and the other thing,
but vase painters as well,
potters of a very special kind.
But that's not all--poets,
singers, liar players,
all of those kinds of
entertainments,
which had been monopolized by
the aristocracy to the degree
they existed at all,
would now be more broadly
available and the tyrants took
pride in bringing the world's
best to their cities and
allowing at least some of them
to hear and see what was going
on.
When we get to Athens I'll be
more specific when we have more
specific information about it.
So that is all part of a story
that would have made the
tyrannies much more widely
supported and not so easy to
knock over as you might think.
People would have had many,
many reasons for gratitude to
the tyrants and would have been
very pleased by much of what the
tyrants were doing.
Of course, the old aristocrats
would have been typically very
unhappy about everything they
were doing, because they had
been cut out.
But if you go to everybody
else, their feelings I think
would have been mixed because
first--I don't know which came
first,
but they would be impressed and
enjoy these positive things.
But they would also be troubled
by something that was counter to
their own traditions and to
central elements of their own
beliefs and concerns.
I keep thinking about those
hoplite farmers,
who have grown to be confident
and independent,
desired to be autonomous,
didn't want to be told what to
do and yet there was somebody
who was doing just that.
So, this is the conflict that
there is.
In fact, what we see is a
steady decline in the popularity
of tyrannies from generation to
generation.
The founder of the tyranny,
he's probably still popular
when he dies.
He did it;
most people are very conscious
of what he achieved,
and he's a glorious figure.
But his son is only tyrant
because he was his son;
it doesn't come from his
personal qualities and when the
people become more and more
aware of the shortcomings,
fewer and fewer people are
interested in the achievements
even though they may do
wonderful things.
By the time you get to the
third generation that's the end.
The third generation of tyrant
gets thrown out if you've made
it that far.
When the tyranny is
overthrown, the typical
successor to the tyrannical
regime is an oligarchy.
I would say it would include
many of the old aristocrats who
had the best land and the
greatest wealth and indeed the
chances are those people would
be the leaders of the new
regime.
But they would very quickly,
because it was not a monarchy
of any kind, would very quickly
form into factions that would be
competing with one another,
based on all kinds of different
things, which would compete with
one another the leader of each
faction,
for becoming the leading
faction, the dominant figures in
the state.
But also, and this is much more
important, the really
fundamental thing is typically,
almost always,
the hoplite class of
independent farmer would have
participated in this regime.
He would have been a full
fledged citizen.
Fighting would be done chiefly
by the phalanx,
with these folks doing the
fighting.
These men would be the economic
backbone of the community,
turning out the grain and the
wine,
and the olive oil and whatever
else, vegetables that they had
to produce and being the
independent fellows that they
were.
Finally,
they would have played a part
in the political life of the
city.
Here, it would vary from town
to town.
You might have a relatively
narrow oligarchy in which the
council was what counted and
that would be typical,
the council would count but it
might be very narrowly defined,
or it could be very broadly
defined,
where it might include all the
hoplites, or something in
between.
But not ever until we get to
Athens would you get a
democracy, the definition being
that every adult male who is
born of native parents is a
citizen and who has some
significant political rights.
That doesn't come yet.
You have an oligarchy meaning
short of that,
but with the variations I've
indicated.
Corinth, for instance,
after they get rid of the
tyrant finally,
becomes famous in the Greek
tradition for the moderation and
therefore the longevity and
peacefulness of its oligarchic
regime.
I think we should imagine that
the Corinthians became a hoplite
city--Not that they didn't have
aristocrats who had wealth and
importance,
but that the hoplites really
played a central part in the
picture.
Just to raise the question,
I remember I raised it about
colonization;
let me raise it about tyranny.
What were the contributions
made by this development in
Greek history to the life of
Greece and they were many.
Obviously, economical growth in
the way I've pointed out,
social change up to a certain
point,
but certainly doing away
forever with the aristocracy of
birth as the normal basis for
citizenship and participation in
the state.
I would go further.
I would say that by destroying
that and substituting for some
kind of an economic basis for
what role you play,
they actually opened the door
for a form of government that
didn't come in many places,
but did come in some,
and I'm talking about a Greek
democracy.
Let me revert finally to
the question of how did Greeks
think about tyranny after
tyranny was gone?
It played a terrific role in
Greek thinking and had a lot to
do with the way the Greeks felt
about their relations with
foreign powers and their own
regimes.
One thing I'll just say in
passing, and come back to it
next time.
Sparta, because of its behavior
in the sixth century and a
little bit into the fifth,
developed a reputation as being
the state that was the enemy of
tyranny.
They never developed a tyranny,
and indeed, they often fought
against tyrants.
When tyranny was gone,
that was seen to be a great
credit to them and helped
explain how it happened that
Sparta emerged and rose to the
level as the leader of the
Greeks which they certainly were
at the time of the Persian Wars.
Beyond that though,
the picture that comes down to
us will be a double picture,
in which opposite elements
exist but certainly the dominant
one is negative.
Tyrannies are arbitrary,
they are violent,
tyrants are arrogant,
they do not permit free speech,
which by the way the Greek
democrats placed in a very
central place in the important
things that are necessary for a
man,
a Greek, a citizen,
a person who is not a
barbarian, the ability to come
forward into the center of
political life and speak your
mind.
When you didn't have that to
some considerable degree,
you were a slave and tyrants
didn't permit that.
There was no true political
life for citizens,
they were de facto
subjects of this tyrant who
himself was an irresponsible,
not responsible to another
body, and therefore,
potentially dangerous and very
easily could become a despot,
which is a Greek word.
Herodotus uses tyranny
critically--well,
you know, by and large,
he depicts the King of Persia,
who finally invades Greece
first in 490 and then another
king in 480, these men are
tyrants,
because they fit precisely the
categorization of tyranny as the
Greeks know it.
In Aeschylus' play,
Prometheus Bound,
Zeus himself is seen to be a
tyrant and the word is used of
him by characters in the play
for the same reason.
He is punishing Prometheus for
his good deeds towards men,
which make men more divine than
they would otherwise be.
Zeus is very angry.
That's because he gave him fire;
Zeus is very,
very angry with him and he
locks him up,
chains him to a rock in the
Caucus Mountains while birds are
pecking away at his liver
forever and ever,
a typical Greek hell of the
worst kind.
And we are led in,
what we have of that play,
to think that Zeus is doing
terrible things.
He is behaving tyrannically,
that is, not good even for the
king of the gods.
Plato, of course,
will regard tyranny later on as
a terribly evil thing and
because of his anti-democratic
prejudices,
will say tyranny is the natural
outcome of democracy because
people can't rule themselves.
They're not competent to do so,
and it's only a matter of time
before some strong,
violent, selfish man makes
himself a tyrant.
It is a distinguishing
feature in Greek thought.
Tyranny or monarchy,
these are not appropriate for
free men.
That is to say Greeks;
Greeks, they felt were by
nature free and they couldn't be
free so long as there was
tyranny.
But tyranny was in fact a
natural way of life for
barbarians, who were not by
nature free men.
So it's helpful.
And this is a form of
ethnocentric stuff,
but the Greeks spelled it out
very carefully,
thought about it very
carefully, and if you had said,
well why do you say that?
Well, they would;
deep down they might hold what
we would call a sort of racial
prejudice, but I think they
would have made a better case
for it.
They would have said,
to be a free man as Aristotle
said, you need to live in a
polis,
because that's the only place
where it's possible to live as a
free man.
So, because Greeks chose to
live in polis,
they are free.
People who choose to live as
the slaves of monarchs and
tyrants, that's because they are
natural slaves.
And that prejudice is very
deep, and so when the Greeks end
up having to fight the Persians,
there's a lot more going on
than just we're being invaded
and we have to defend our land.
Next time I'll look at the
great exception to all of the
things we've been talking about:
Sparta, the state like no other
Greek state.